si un truc bien un truc et je vais être
honnête une fois on s'est engueulé c'est
vrai ça a été très très loin ouais ouais
on était à deux doigts d insulte la mont
vinson tu t'éclates et un sur strike
alors il ya beaucoup de médias qui ont
fait les gros titres ouais on va revenir
là dessus en révélant que tu avais dit
qu'il fallait qu'on démarre à 21h12
alors on va on va se mettre d'accord
tout de suite avec vincent on a discuté
de tout cet été tous les deux on
s'appelait plein de fois on s'est appelé
way 10 - 19 fois c'est ça ouais et on
s'est arrêté sur 21h12 et ça a été
transformé il ya eu entre toi et moi et
lionel et la chaîne le produit 10
minutes de marchands de tapis
c'est ça ouais j'ai dit j'aimerais qu'on
puisse démarrer l'émission à une heure
fixe
alors tu m'as dit quelle heure tu veux
démarrer si on démarre à 21h05 c'est
bien et toi tu as dis non c'est pas
possible
21h20 21h10 après 21h15 et aussi arrêté
à 28 ans et c'est pas démarré à 21h12
c'est essayer de faire en sorte que le
programme ne démarre pas après les gars
étaient 1h12
c'est pas du tout je veux que ça soit 21
ans 12 j'ai eu d'autres exigences qui
sont par exemple je veux absolument non
mais justement temps passant parce qu'on
va l'été ensemble on va faire un vrai
faux ou sur les exigences à madame
lagarde c'est parti elle devrait fournir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je voulais dire à beaucoup de lui
dire qu'ils ont révélé des trucs mais
voilà nous on va vous dire toute la
vérité ce soir donc c'est le vrai faux
est ce que vincent lagaf a demandé à
avoir cinq personnes pour s'occuper de
sa coiffure sont bien sûr bien sûr c'est
faux ouah ça est ce que vincent lagaf a
demandé que strike commencer
obligatoirement à 21h12 très précisément
dit oui on s'est mis d'accord tous les
deux ce sera 21h12 tous les mercredis on
croit à fond à ce programme qui a déjà
cartonné et je vous le dis il y aura
exactement
pour l'instant il y aura quinze semaines
de strike pendant 15 semaines tournée 30
modules de 40 minutes qui fait 15
émissions 15 émissions donc avec vincent
tous les mercredis vous le retrouverez
pendant 15 semaines et voilà donc il n'y
a pas eu de problème il m'a dit oui je
veux absolument on discute tous les deux
prochains jours il dit lui et moi et je
voulais dire on discute de tout ça veut
dire on peut même 10 quand on arrive à
se parler au téléphone parce que ça
c'est quoi cet été on a pu les
éclairages horaire entre monaco et
cavaleur soit elle ce que vincent lagaf
a demandé qu isabelle morini-bosc
passons 2007 dans sa loge avant le
château royal a demandé mais il n'a pas
eu malheureusement elle n'a pas ie n'a
pas pu s que vincent exigé que fort
boyard ne soit pas diffusée le mercredi
sur france 4
oui oui parce que il est dans fort
boyard vincent et cirés d'aironi de fort
boyard et a demandé à la chaîne ne pas
le mettre en face de toi c'est normal ça
me paraît un peu respectueux par rapport
à ceux qui y travaillent mais en plus
c'est franchement et france téléthon dit
oui ou pas absolument faux ni stocker de
confiance souci est ce que vincent lagaf
a utilisé que ces huit produits sa
sextape intitulé chauffe mois les bulls
germa qui
[Rires]
alors gilles vous n'avez pas compris les
exigences de façon je vais vous
expliquer parce que voilà comme ça ce
sera fait c'est que vincent je leur dis
et je te jure
franchement ça se passe très très bien
entre vincent et moi
vincent je croyais pas qu'il allait tout
autant voilà à l'ecoute il écoute la
productrice
il écoute les tout le monde il est il
donne des avis il donne son il donne des
idées
il est passé pas il vient il arrive il
fait son truc et y rentre chez lui et
s'investit pas du tout moi je le dis je
suis très heureux de travailler dans mon
sens que tu investis à fond dans strike
c'est un truc qui compte vraiment pour
toi et quand il fait une émission
il y va à fond il prépare des truies qui
préparent des chorégraphes il prépare
des entrées et préparent des vannes
c'est un bosseur et c'est un bonheur de
travailler que toi il a joué tous les
deux il arrive qu'on soit pas d'accord
sur des trucs bas mais on en parle on en
parle c'est sympa mais on se parle de
tout avec vinci à aucun moment il ya une
prise d'otages et aucun moment il ya
exigence non mais c'est sûr jamais eu
des guirlandes la seule chose qui m'a
fait pas de la peine mais qui m'est fait
chier c'est quand tu as dit mais qui
sait ce mec pour exiger sa d'abord suis
que je suis je le dois à personne je
sais d'où je viens et je sais où je vais
et comment j'y vais c'est dans tes
propos c'est la phrase qui m'a gêné
hélas la phrase qui m'a gêné de
jean-michel c'est que j'ai pris le
boulard non non lorsque je me dis c'est
pas une question de boulard et je me
suis je vais répondre à passe de vincent
c'est que vincent vous jure il veut il
veut que tout soit carré de a à z c'est
un gros bosseur franchement moi je vous
le dit c'est il est pour vous dire pour
penser que france 4 ne renie fusent pas
fort boyard en même temps que strike il
faut quand même y penser
et ça ça doit vous faire justement moi
j'adore voilà parce que healy sur des
petits détails on se met d'accord même
sur les pubs sur les pubs voilà on peut
pas les longs c'est n'importe quoi
et ben va même façon même s'il va le
regarder avec nous on va regarder quel
est le meilleur moment
on a eu on n'était pas content le dit la
vérité du lancement des pubs sur les
premiers numéros ce qui s'est passé sur
la pub c'est qu'on nous avait dit mettez
la pub à telle heure au moment du
chronométrage avec le time code on a vu
qu'on arrivait à peu près à cette heure
là et on a fait un lancement plus
mesdames et messieurs on se retrouve
dans quelques instants après la pub on
est de retour sur le plateau de strike
et puis finalement ça correspondait pas
l'heure exacte à laquelle la chaîne
voulait diffuser la pub donc ils ont
taillé dedans et je trouve que c'est pas
artistique s'était pas jolie coque ça
s'arrête même bizarre ça reprend alors
je leur ai dit soit vous savez
précisément où on met la pub soit et
c'est ce qu'on a fait je vous enregistre
trois quatre coupures pub est dedans
vous choisissez on a réussi à son temps
ne s'était pas une exigence c'est beau
c'est en hectares dans le même sens
alors c'est vous dire à chaque début
d'émission d'affaires d entrée grandiose
pouvez poser toutes les questions à
vincent autour de la table et on regarde
par exemple dans l'émission de demain
vous prenez vous prenez pour un vrai
biker c'est très fort regardez pas
terrain d'ailleurs babolat pas merci au
revoir on l'a pas à nous les chéris nom
et vous avez un nouvel acolyte dans
l'émission si c'est youssef bokbot 1 640
kg peu peur avec 140 kg une épaule de
lui c'est moi complet demain ce seront
des bas ce sera les invités de ce
trailer demain on à sébastien chabal
hervé mathoux il chantait tellement reçu
d'un couvent dans la savane hervé
mathoux demain héritier de ses livres
kelly vélo belli ça a été un bonheur de
t'avoir sur le plateau on s'est éclaté
mais il vraiment j'ai un grand moment
j'étais découvert sous un autre jour et
tu reviens quand tu veux j'entends
parfaitement les explications de cyril
et les vôtres moi je me place tour du
point de vue du lecteur du
téléspectateur on voit un jour les
exigences de la gaffe
alors si c'est les journalistes oui oui
on en met d'accord mais on avait débattu
de ça et moi je vous le redis les yeux
dans les yeux j'ai adoré votre retour
j'ai toujours milité pour que vous
reveniez à la télé vous êtes une star
mais là ça m'avait paru des caprices de
star et je n'aime pas ça donc je l'avais
dit voilà c'était une liste et pour moi
c'est pas du perfectionnisme c'était
trop c'est pour ça que j'avais dit ça je
le retire rien mais si je voulais
blesser sur la phrase mais qui sait je
m'en excuse mais je ne retire rien de ce
que j'avais dit voilà mais vous avez
tout à fait raison seulement
c'est vrai que c'est monté par les
journalistes pour faire un petit peu du
sensationnel
il n'y a aucune exigence en dehors du
fait que je veux qu'ils absolument
personne dans les couloirs quand je me
déplace et d'avoir faire seulement une
usine allemande pour me déplacer
tous savent que ces nouveaux moulins du
secteur réalisée après oui oui elle
réside bel oui peut-être question et
vincent tu as tourné énormément de
strike
la première a fait un carton à 1 million
400 m haies téléspectateurs quels sont
tes pronostics pour les suivantes chaque
mercredi
c'est cette question là non merci je me
donne le temps de réfléchir et parvient
on y reviendra je vais donner mon
pronostique aussi pour de barmon façon
alors oui surtout tournent autour du
million je serais très très bien at war
et north bay oui je disais que c'est
très intéressant les téléspectateurs
doivent vraiment et cette émission est
très bien parce que les gens peuvent
s'exprimer
et moi j'étais je pensais comme gilles
je l'avais dit aussi moi j'ai été étonné
on avait l'impression que c'était pamela
anderson en danse avec les stars
jetables et moi ouais pareil
bref nommé journalistes mais il avait
présent moi je le redis vraiment vincent
ça a été je te disais mais c'est
vraiment le gars je l'appelle je me dis
des trucs qui me rappelle on se dit on
se dit les choses
il n'y a pas du tout de stars ne sont
pas du tout si un truc bien un truc et
je vais encore va être honnête
une fois on s'est engueulé ça va ça a
été très très loin ouais ouais on était
à deux doigts d un succès il ya quelques
années quand vous aviez fait un sujet
sur les salaires et que gérard louvin à
l'époque avait dit une connerie grosses
comme lui c'est à dire la taille de la
connerie et en disant que je gagnais
200000 euros par jour une grosse
connerie flash était parti en colère et
là on s'était pris on sais pas c'était
prix shaw s'est maintenant lancé par
émission c'est par semaine oui par
semaine le succès par semaine par
semaine
oui tous bords taxes
[Musique]